ESTABLISHMENT BY CHARLIE AND
BEN, SO GREAT TO SEE YOU
TONIGHT.
AND NOW, ALLIES?
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHENEVER BIDEN MEETS WITH WORLD
LEADERS ESPECIALLY WHEN HE IS
OVER IN EUROPE, YOU KNOW AMERICA
IS GOING TO GET TAKEN TO THE
CLEANERS ONE WAY OR ANOTHER AND
TODAY WAS NO EXCEPTION.
DURING HIS MEETING WITH THE G7,
THIS IS WHAT WENT DOWN.
BEFORE BIDEN EVEN SHOWED UP,
AMERICA GOT LECTURED FIGHT
SEVERAL OF OUR SO-CALLED ALLIES.
SO FRANCE, CANADA, IN THE UK
FELT THE NEED TO RESPOND TO THE
SUPREME COURT'S DECISION TO
OVERTURN ROE VERSUS WADE WAS
VERY SHARP CRITICISM -- WITH
VERY SHARP CRITICISM.
FOR BORIS JOHNSON WHO DESTROYED
THE TORY PARTY JOINING THAT TO
PILE ON THE U.S. FOR HIM, THAT
IS REALLY RICH BECAUSE HE DID
NOT TELL YOU THAT THE UNITED
KINGDOM IN MANY WAYS HAS PET
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION THAT
MANY STATES IN THE UNITED
STATES.
BECAUSE THEY REQUIRE TWO DOCTORS
TO SIGN OFF ON AN ABORTION IN
THE UK.
NOW, BORIS' CRITIQUE IS AN
EFFORT TO BOLSTER BIDEN INTO
APPEAR AS A UNIFIER IN PUSHING
FOR MORE UKRAINE AID TO.
GOOD LUCK IN UNIFYING ANYONE ON
THEIR.
THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME NOT
WILL LIKELY BE THE LAST AT OUR
ALLIES IN NAME ONLY HAVE
EXPRESSED STRONG OPPOSITION TO
MARY POPPINS CONSERVATIVE
POPULIST MOVEMENT PICKUP UPDATE
HATED TRUMP, OF COURSE.
FOR A LOT OF REASONS BUT CHIEF
AMONG THEM, IT WAS HIS DEMENTED
THAT EUROPE SPENT MORE ON THEIR
MILITARY AFTER DECADES OF
ESSENTIALLY WHAT WAS FREE RIDING
ON THE UNITED STATES BUT WHEN
YOU REMEMBER ON TRUMP WHEN HE
WOULD GO OVER THERE, HE IS
PRETTY PRAGMATIC BUT HE WAS
UNABASHEDLY PRO-AMERICAN AND WAS
CONSISTENTLY BLEND.
THREE QUALITIES THE EUROPEANS
GENTLY LOADS ABOUT ASPECT.
EUROPEANS PREFER PRESIDENTS WHO
BADMOUTH OR APOLOGIZE FOR
AMERICA.
FIRST, OBAMA.
>> President Obama: AMERICA HAS
SHOWN ARROGANCE AND BEEN
DISMISSIVE, EVEN DERISIVE.
WE HAVE A LEGACY OF SEGREGATION.
I WOULD UP THE.
>> OF NATIVE AMERICANS.
THERE ARE TIMES WE SOUGHT TO
DICTATE [INDISTINCT].
>> Laura: HE WAS EMBARRASSED AND
DID NOT CLEAR THAT HIS SLAMMING
HURT OUR MORAL STANDING ON
CRITICAL ISSUES.
AND HIS TALKING AMERICA DOWNWARD
HAS -- ONLY GOTTEN WORSE WITH
THE CURRENT OCCUPANT OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> President Biden: THE
AMERICAN EXPERIMENT IN DEMOCRACY
IS IN A DANGER LIKE IT HAS NOT
BEEN IN MY LIFETIME.
I WOULD LIKE IT IS IN DANGER
THIS HOUR.
>> Vice President Harris: THE
ANTI-VOTER LAWS ARE PART OF AN
INTENTIONAL EFFORT TO EXCLUDE
AMERICANS FROM PARTICIPATING IN
OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> THIS CORRUPTION HERE AT HOME
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO HELP
PEOPLE THING TAXES OR HOW THEY
DON'T.
>> President Biden: RACISM,
THE UGLY POISON THAT HAS HAUNTED
OUR NATION.
>> Laura: A RACIST NATION THAT
ALSO HATES WOMEN.
BIDEN ALSO BELIEVES OUR SUPREME
COURT NOW IS MISOGYNISTIC.
ANOTHER GREAT MESSAGE FOR OUR
CHILDREN AND THE WORLD PAC
PAPER.
>> Laura: IT IS THE REALIZATION
OF AN EXTREME IDEOLOGY SO
EXTREME THAT THEY WERE FORCED TO
BEAR THEIR RAPISTS' CHILD.
>> Laura: AND EVEN THINKING IT
WAS PERFECTLY FINE TO MAKE OUR
TAXPAYERS THAT LINE'S SHARE --
LION PROFIT SHARE OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE WHEN THEY AGREED THAT
THEY ARE UNANIMOUS THAT THE
DEADLINES WILL SUPPORT UKRAINE I
WILL TELL YOU WHAT THAT MEANS.
THAT AMERICANS SHOULD BE
PREPARED TO DEFUND A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF THE
WAR EFFORTS FOR YEARS.
BIDEN'S SECURITY ADVISER.
MONEY GROWS ON TREES AND HE
SEEMS -- HAS SEEN REPORTS.
>> I HAVE SEEN THE REPORTS OF
SPECIFIC DETAILS AROUND ADVANCED
AIR DEFENSE CAPABILITIES PICK UP
I CAN CONFIRM THAT WE ARE IN
FACT IN THE PROCESS OF
FINALIZING A PACKAGE THAT
INCLUDES ADVANCED AIR DEFENSE
CAPABILITIES.
VENMOED THIS IS COMPLETE
MANAGEMENT UKRAINE IS LOSING THE
WAR AND BIDEN HAS NO IDEA WHAT
HE IS DOING AND WHO TRUSTS HIM?
BACK IN MAY, CONGRESS APPROVED A
STAGGERING $40 BILLION UKRAINE
AID PACKAGE WHICH INCLUDED
$5 BILLION IN WHAT WE WERE TOLD
CONGRESS ASSURED US WAS A
EMERGENCY FOOD ASSISTANCE THE
AREAS HARDEST HIT BY.
THERE WERE HARDEST HIT BY THE
WAY FOR STARVATION.
THAT WAS THE RISK THEY REPRESENT
DUE TO THE CONFLICT AND ALL THE
AGRICULTURAL LAW.
ACCORDING TO THE POLITICO, MORE
THAN A MONTH AFTER CHRIS
APPROVED THAT, USAID AND THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAVE TO
SIGN OUT ANY OF THE FUNDS THAT
EVEN AS PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HIS
TOP OFFICIALS INCREASED THEIR
PUBLIC WARNINGS ABOUT THE WAR'S
IMPACT ON FOOD PRICES.
OKAY.
THE GUY WHO CAN HANDLE 5 BILLION
THINKS HE SHOULD BE TRUSTED WITH
MOBILIZING $600 BILLION.
THINK OF THE POTENTIAL FOR FRAUD
AND ABUSE ESPECIALLY SINCE BIDEN
IS BETTING ON A TRIFECTA, A
GLOBALIST GREENE THE I FANTASY.
>> President Biden: WE HAD TO
MOBILIZE NEARLY $600 BILLION
FROM THE G7 BY 2027.
THESE STRATEGIC INVESTMENTS ARE
AREAS OF CRITICAL TO SUSTAINABLE
DEVELOPMENT AND TO OUR SHARED
GLOBAL STABILITY.
HEALTH AND HEALTH SECURITY.
DIGITAL CONNECTIVITY.
GENDER EQUALITY AND EQUITY.
CLIMATE AND ENERGY SECURITY.
>> THAT IS A SOCIALIST MOUTHFUL,
ISN'T IT?
WHY WERE THEY WEARING CREEPY
COSTUMES?
WHEN BIDEN SAYS COLLECTIVELY AND
HE WANTS TO MOBILIZE THE
600 BILLION, WHO DO YOU THINK IS
GOING TO PICK UP MOST OF THAT
TAB?
YOU, THAT IS HUBIG BUT DON'T
WORRY BECAUSE OUR ALLIES ARE
CHEERING BIDEN AS HE ALSO SPELLS
OUT U.S. MANUFACTURING.
>> President Biden: JUST
FACILITATED A NEW PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN TWO AMERICAN FIRMS AND
THAT GOVERNMENT AND ANGOLA TO
INVEST $2 BILLION IN BUILDING A
NEW SOLAR PROJECT IN ANGOLA.
IT IS A PARTNERSHIP THAT WILL
HELP ANGOLA ME ITS CLIMATE
GOALS.
>> Laura: OF COURSE OUR ALLIES
ARE UP FRONT ABOUT ALL OF THIS.
AFTER ALL, YOU AMERICA HAVE A
LOT TO ATONE FOR ESPECIALLY
UNDER TRUMP.
WHEN OUR ECONOMY WAS FAR
OUTPATIENT EUROPE PICKUP.
REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT?
NO INFLATION.
FAMILIES CONNECTION GO ON
VACATION.
PEOPLE WERE PRETTY OPTIMISTIC.
THAT MADE THE ELITE ESPECIALLY
THAT EURO ELITE MISERABLE.
IF AMERICANS COULD BE SO FREE
AND PROSPEROUS, IT WAS ONLY A
MATTER OF TIME BEFORE THEIR OWN
PEOPLE DEMANDED BY THE RESULTS
THEM AND EUROPE.
JUST LOOK AT THE TROUBLED
MCCRONE -- TROUBLE MACRON IS
HAVING NOW.
BIDEN IS GOING TO GIVE THEM
ANYTHING THEY WANT AND HE WILL
ASK ZERO IN RETURN.
THE TIME HAS COME FOR
REPUBLICANS TO ASK THEMSELVES,
WHICH COUNTRIES ARE TRULY ALLIES
OF THE UNITED STATES AT WHICH
ARE ONLY ALLIES OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY?
BECAUSE IF THE PURPOSE OF THIS
ALLIANCE IS TO PROMOTE ABORTION,
CLIMATE MANDATES, AND AT THIS
POINT THIS IS BETTING ON WARS,
HOW CAN WE ESTIMATE CAN SOLDIERS
MANY OF WHOM BY THE WAY ARE
DEVOUTLY RELIGIOUS TO FIGHT AND
POSSIBLY DIE FOR US?
FOR THAT MATTER IF OUR ALLIES
ARE ONLY WILLING TO HELP THE
DEMOCRATS BUT NEVER THE
REPUBLICANS, WHY SHOULD
REPUBLICANS IN